Her low freak bitches and I did my first
marathon in 2002 so I've been doing
this for whatever,
14 years.
Um,
multiple marathons
every year back to back.
Sometimes my body is not 100%,
so I can push,
I have a high high pain tolerance,
but eventually,
um,
it adds up.
And so it's pain for me.
Is this,
who was a joint pain?
Knees,
everything.
Is it just the whole body?
It's waste down,
hips,
knees,
ankles,
feet.
And how long does it take you to recover?
Like you were telling me that your legs
were swollen twice the size of normal.
Yeah,
last year.
Last year was way worse.
This year I had,
I've put in a bunch of miles leading up.
I was running about a
half a marathon a day.
So my body was pretty fit
and pretty used to it.
So my recovery was much shorter.
I mean I,
and again
people aren't going to understand this,
but the next,
the day after I ran 102 I ran 13 miles
and that was just because when I run the
big foot 200 I'm going to have
to be able to come back after,
you know,
multiple days of being hurt and banged
up and that's the name of the game,
you know,
to cover 200 miles and a
couple of days like I want to,
I'm not going to be 100%
so I thought well I can't,
I can't know what it feels like to run
after I run a hundred miles unless one I
run a hundred miles and
two I run the day after.
So you can't simulate that.
There's no way to simulate that.
So you ran 13 miles a day
after you run 102 miles,
what the fuck is that like?
Uh,
it'd be using the running term loosely.
It was painful.
Slow.
I was hiking the up hills
running would be like,
it would,
I probably looked like a 90 year old
man trying to run it frickin hurt.
And what are you legs?
Totally swollen.
We doing this?
Yeah.
My,
uh,
my ankles are all swollen and calves that
don't really have an ankle it so same
size from my foot up and yeah,
I mean it's not good for me.
I mean it's not in anybody who
talks about doing hundreds,
hundreds aren't good for probably anybody.
So it's,
it's,
yeah,
I know that what I do isn't in
the best interest of my body,
but it's just the name of the game.
So what I do do this cock,
Jamie pulled up the
fucking definition is this,
an urban dictionary says
a better definition,
I think than the one you gave.
Oh.
How dare you.
Demasculated millennial liberal male
who often speaks of white privilege and
modern feminism blames white men
for all of the world's problems.
The new definition or
I like,
I like this though.
There goes chat again with the
telling everyone that he's a Vegan.
What a cook.
Okay.
I like that.
I liked that a lot.
But um,
look up cock,
hold on here.
But cock hold is different.
It's a different,
uh,
short for cuckservative what they fucking
till word cock is most commonly used
on Twitter to describe anti white males
while it was originally formed with the
original meaning of cock cock hold.
The use of the word cock does not
necessarily denote a sexual connotation.
Wow.
It's morphing.
The language is evolving before our eyes.
Cox do not care about Islamic countries
throwing gays off buildings or hanging
them as much as the cake Baker,
who is Christian and warrant
served gay wedding customers.
Oh,
that's interesting.
Coxe.
Give a free pass to anyone who criticized
them for fear of looking racist or
homophobic.
We'll still have that
lady in Germany is a cook.
The word originated from
white nationalists vocabulary,
but it's still widely used by all.
Okay.
But that,
so,
but they took caught hold and
turned it into this new thing go to.
But what is the definition for Koc hole?
So this has nothing to do with guys'
wives getting bang by Chris does me.
It's still real to me,
dammit.
It's also like an official definition
that an old dictionary from old English,
Oh means a man whose wife
was unfaithful cut cold,
which is yeah.
Yeah,
to make a cuckold of so if you,
okay,
that's uh,
that's how Norton I think
described it to me like a man.
If you,
if your wife is out banging other dudes
and you know about it but you don't say
anything,
you become a cock hold.
But there's also like cock hold porn where
it's like I said the guys there while
like sobbing in the corner
while his wife gets grilled.
Fucked.
Interesting.
The world is evolving.
It's beautiful.
So it's still open,
open season then for use
cook anyway you want,
because we were really just
hit like five definitions.
I still have a fucking clue what I mean.
Yeah.
I mean a bunch of cooks sensitive cooks.
I liked that one definition though.
The the,
the Vegan,
it's gets on the megaphone.
It's usually a Vegan who's been
a Vegan for like a month to,
all right.
Those are my favorite fucking Cox
boy.
How do you pull out of this
and have a normal conversation?
Where are we?
Do
we go from here,
Joe?
We always say you're either a hunter,
you're like Brendon
mentioned a berry picker,
and it's in our DNA if you're a hunter.
And to be able to test that against the
toughest conditions against the hardest
animals to hunt in the most remote places
is to me the ultimate test of being a
human being and ultimate
test of being a hunter.
And that's what drives me and what
we do and why they train year round.
Why I'm always thinking about gear,
about food,
about Wade,
about uh,
what,
uh,
how I could improve from what I learned
on last year to this coming seasons.
Um,
and preparation of it is a,
it's fun.
Yeah,
I love it.
I live it and breathe it and uh,
it's,
it's challenging.
It's really challenging.
Well,
it unfolded for me,
uh,
and it still continues to do so cause
I've only been doing it for four years.
I mean,
Rinella got me involved and he
took me out to Montana in 2012.
And uh,
you know,
I was like,
Oh hey,
this is kind of be interesting.
Let's see what this is all about,
because I had watched shows
and I read some stuff about it,
but one of the things that he said,
he's like,
man,
there's a steep learning curve to this.
There's a steep lines and it goes long.
And I was like,
well,
how long can it go?
He fucking find an anime,
shoot it and kill it and eat.
It would seem so hard.
But then as you get into it,
you realize,
and then of course bow hunting,
which is the most difficult
of the most difficult pursuit.
And as you get into it,
you realize like,
oh,
this is like some crazy puzzle.
It's like some crazy challenge that you
have to figure that also involves a way
to procure your food.
It does.
And it's a skill set you
never quit learning on.
Every time you go,
I learned something new.
Yeah,
there's a,
there's a natural
progression you go through.
I mean it's like you're
just excited to be there.
Right?
And then your,
and then you,
you see it with people you've
take out for the first time.
They're just like,
oh,
kind of what's what's going on here.
And you know,
and then then all of a sudden they
get a little click and it's like,
I want to get one,
you know?
And then,
you know,
that's usually a couple of years and then,
and then,
yeah,
I want to get an,
I'm going to get a nicer one than
one I got last time and I want,
you want to do something
a little more challenging.
And it just keeps progressing until like,
you know,
till you get,
wherever it ends.
And it's,
it's you,
you're hunting the,
the toughest animals,
the biggest animals,
the oldest animals in the toughest
conditions and being successful and,
and a lot of people won't get there,
but it's,
it's,
it's always a challenge.
It's something that never gets old.
I mean,
it's,
you know,
it was comparable to any athletic event.
Only you can do it for your whole life,
you know?
I mean,
there's lots of stuff you do athletic
and then in growing up or whatever,
and it's like,
but it doesn't really translate,
you know,
a college wrestler that doesn't translate
that well to write the rest of your
life.
Exactly.
You're that dude down there at
the intermural wrestling like,
ah,
you've missed,
you know,
hunting is one thing that is
just throughout your entire life.
Depending on where you're at.
I mean,
you can,
it's,
you can always continue
to learn and pursue it.
And you know,
sometimes you,
you know,
you don't have a ton of time
you can do a short on sometimes,
you know,
things are going well,
you can do something that's,
you know,
an epic adventure.
But it's always a challenge.
It never gets easy though.
I mean,
the,
the animal you killed
last time does not care.
The,
the new animal you're hunting does
not care what you got last time.
You have to go out.
You gotta be sharp every single time.
Yeah.